Brett McMurphy has been at this for
quite some time in the this being a
covering sports in covering college
football longtime reporter for CBS
Sports and also ESPN and he broke the
story over the last several days from
his Facebook page as to what Urban Meyer
may have known and what he did not know
potentially about his wide receiver
coach Zach Smith battering his wife
there's no other way to put it and Brett
McMurphy is here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Brett good afternoon rich
good afternoon
so what do you know right now that it
having maybe advanced the story from
what you you were already able to glean
through text messages and for
conversations with those involved well
obviously you know the Ohio State after
my report Wednesday announced that they
would investigate the allegations and
then yesterday they announced that a
six-man committee special independent
board working group related to the
investigation I reached out to about two
dozen athletic direct current athletic
directors across the country in the past
by 12 hours in saying what do you guys
think this means I got a as you can
expect a lot of different opinions the
general consensus is obviously the Ohio
State has to find out exactly what
happened if they have any thoughts of
bringing him back that means they're
going to have to be going through four
or five years of text messages from
Urban Meyer from Shoei Meyer from all
their staff members maybe even family
members and even if they do that is
there the concern that if they don't
find anything and they decide to bring
him back some other evidence comes up
that he indeed that he and did indeed
excuse me did know about 2015 most I
believe it's basically that they're
looking to reach some kind of settlement
with Meyer I guess the large part of it
is if urban decides to fight this and if
he does then this will probably be a
long drawn-out process 180 was pretty
animated basically said in today's
landscape Ohio State the president is
I'll won't use his language but blank
lists
scared because of what happened at
Baylor what happen at Penn State I'm not
comparing those situations with with
Ohio State but basically in those
situations
both the ABS and the president got fired
he said when when things start going
downhill and can be proven and life can
be proven then everyone runs for the
hills and it can't get out of hand you
don't know where it goes so he think he
thinks that maybe some of the mindset
also but ultimately if Urban Meyer digs
his heels in then they'll conclude you
know conduct the investigation I think
it could go on for a long time but if
there's no evidence that his wife did
tell him right then in in that in that
the story might be just like how could a
wife who knows about what's going on
based again on your reporting in the
text messages not tell her husband and
if the if Ohio State accepts that then
then it's possible that despite how that
might be handled internally in the Urban
Meyer household is that feasible I mean
because if we cannot take him at his
word and it not that they don't trust
him but there's too much at risk here
and yes I did not find any text messages
Courtney Smith did not provide any text
messages that Urban Meyer from Urban
Meyer that directly said he knew about
it but when you look at the volumes of
text messages she showed me back and
forth between her and Shelley Meyer and
other members of the staff of the excuse
me wives of the staff members and then
you the fact that Courtney and Shelley
had multiple conversations about this
Shelley feared for for Courtney's life
and then go back to 2009 when Zach Smith
was an assistant at Florida he was
arrested for aggravated assault on a
pregnant female Courtney was 10 weeks
pregnant it was on the one-year wedding
anniversary
Courtney dropped the charges she told me
in part because harm DeFries who was it
forwarded in and his official title Ohio
State now is special assistant to the
head coach he pressured her to drop the
charges she went through with it decided
to drop the charges during that time
urban said at Big Ten media days that
him and Shelly counseled the young
couple back in 2009 to help them out so
let's fast forward to 2015
Shelley Meyer is aware that domestic
violence issues are now prevalent with
Courtney Smith and now she's not going
to tell even when they discounsel the
couple four or five years ago that with
all of these text messages and the fact
that literally everybody in the Woody
Hayes Athletic Center had to know about
it I find it hard to believe that all
these people knew about it plus you've
got police reports from the Palo hiyo
police report department that a reporter
that's currently unemployed living in
Tampa Florida such as myself was able to
obtain all these people know about it
yet
Urban Meyer had no knowledge of it rich
I just find that impossible to believe
so then what's this is it just as simple
then based on again while you're just on
the speculation right - why I mean is it
just because he didn't want to do this
Darryl Bruce's grandson is that
essentially what it is because it's not
like as if you can get another wide
receiver coach to win 73 out of 81 games
right I mean I've been asked that
question about you know that's literally
one of two questions I would ask Urban
Meyer is why did you keep him because
you know if what happened in 2009 when
he first brought Zack Smith on a staff
at Florida that's because of Earl Bruce
he has said or Bruce's second most
important male in his life behind his
father that makes a total sense he was a
grad assistant he then left and went to
Marshall and temple my returns to
coaching in 2012 he hired Zack Smith his
wide receivers coach obviously that was
because of Earl Bruce but then once
these domestic violence and XI issues
surface again in 2015 and and Courtney
said actually 2014 then why do you keep
the guy because you can get you can get
a thousand guys you can get HEC you and
I could coach Ohio State's wide
receivers and they don't have the same
production he wasn't this unbelievable
wide receivers coach so why do you hang
on to him who is Courtney that she says
again this is her opinion
says Zach not her opinion but she said
Zach told her that if he ever this ever
came out and he went down he would take
everyone down at Ohio State with him is
that an empty threat does he have actual
information that could damage the
program I don't know I asked Kourtney
and she said she doesn't know
specifically what he was referring to
was that an empty threat does he
legitimately have some things I don't
know maybe that's one reason he would
keep him that long
I just find a hard way somebody that
with the success that Urban Meyer has
had would risk his career just because
this was Bruce's grandson and this was
the second time they've gone through
this domestic violence since she I'm
about Bret McMurphy here in the Rich
Eisen show I mean unless urban didn't
think he was putting his career on the
line keeping him there IIIi don't know
you know so I what you asked me what
that was if I two questions to ask askin
that would be one the other one would be
why did you deny that you knew about it
and in Tuesday's press conference
because that was it excuse me a Big Ten
media days because one day I reported
about Florida and that Courtney had been
issued a received a protection order
Zach Smith was prohibited from
contacting her for the next five years
that had not been previously reported I
got that information from simple public
record requests I reported that Monday
morning Ohio State said we have a no
comment
five o'clock Monday night I reported the
2015 incident which what the police
report I had obtained it was not public
information fifty minutes after that
they fired Zach Smith Tuesday at Big Ten
media days Urban Meyer has asked about
that urban says I don't know why someone
would create a story like that
I'm thinking to myself I'm the one that
created it because I got the police
report on my hand he said he looked into
it there was no information and so when
I talked to I asked urban directly later
on Tuesday I said you said 2009 didn't
happen you see
2015 never occurred basically I made up
the story then why did you fire in 50
minutes after I reported it the school
had no additional information from my
previous report Monday morning so what
changed between when I fought when I
filed a second story and then your
decision to fire him his direct quote
was that ship has sailed and he then
said he would only discuss this year's
team
Bret McMurphy here on the Rich Eisen
show seven last question for you here in
this instance is how do you think this
does play out and when the liability
that Ohio State would have if they
brought him back and you know we haven't
even touched on a big part of it and
whether that's fair or not you know
other people can debate that but the
reality is how much of a PR hit is a
high estate going to take if they bring
back a guy that's perceived as an
enabler to domestic violence especially
you know in today's landscape and how
sensitive we are to those to that and
certainly what's going on currently with
the Ohio State with which former coaches
and staff members and what happened at
Michigan State I think ultimately they
they reach a settlement with the Urban
Meyer I don't think he will ever coach
again at Ohio State Brett excellent
reporting and appreciate the phone call
we'll have you back on as this story
progresses appreciate thank you very
much Rick so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience